Je veux que nous commencions par penser à cet appareil,
le téléphone qui est probablement dans vos poches actuellement.
Plus de 40% d'Américains vérifient leur téléphone
dans les cinq minutes qui suivent leur réveil le matin.
Puis ils le regardent encore une cinquantaine de fois dans la journée.
Les adultes considèrent cet appareil indispensable.
Je veux que vous l'imaginiez dans les mains d'un enfant de trois ans
et, en tant que société, cela nous angoisse.
Les parents ont peur
que cet appareil retarde la croissance sociale de leur enfant ;
qu'il les empêche de se lever et de bouger ;
que d'une certaine façon,
cela perturbe leur enfance.
J'aimerais remettre en question cette attitude.
Je peux imaginer un futur
où nous serions enthousiastes à l'idée de voir un enfant interagir avec un écran.
Ces écrans peuvent pousser les enfants à se lever et bouger encore plus.
Ils ont le pouvoir de nous en dire plus sur ce qu'un enfant apprend
qu'un test standardisé.
Et voici l'idée absolument folle :
je crois que ces écrans ont le pouvoir
de susciter plus de conversations dans la vie réelle
entre les enfants et leurs parents.
Je suis peut-être un défenseur inattendue de cette cause.
J'ai étudié la littérature pour enfants
car j'allais travailler avec des enfants et des livres.
Mais il y a environ 20 ans,
j'ai vécu une expérience qui a changé mon projet
J'aidais à mener une étude sur les enfants d'école maternelle et les sites internet.
Je suis arrivée et on m'a assigné une fille de trois ans, Maria.
Maria n'avait jamais vu d'ordinateur auparavant.
J'ai dû d'abord lui apprendre à utiliser la souris
et quand j'ai ouvert l'écran, elle l'a déplacée sur l'écran
et s'est arrêtée sur un personnage appelé X la chouette.
Quand elle a fait cela,
la chouette a levé son aile et lui a fait signe.
Maria a lâché la souris, s'est écartée de la table, s'est levée d'un bond
et lui a fait signe frénétiquement.
Le lien qu'elle avait avec ce personnage
était viscéral.
Ce n'était pas une expérience passive devant un écran.
C'était une expérience humaine.
Et c'était tout à fait approprié pour un enfant de trois ans.
Je travaille à PBS Kids depuis plus de 15 ans
et je me concentre sur l'exploitation du pouvoir de la technologie
pour un impact positif sur la vie des enfants.
Je crois qu'en tant que société, nous manquons une belle opportunité.
Nous laissons notre peur et notre scepticisme,
au sujet de ces appareils,
nous empêcher de réaliser leur potentiel
dans la vie de nos enfants.
La peur concernant les enfants et la technologie n'est pas nouvelle,
nous avons connu cela auparavant.
Il y a plus de 50 ans,
des débats faisaient rage sur le nouveau média dominant :
la télévision.
Cette boite dans le salon ?
Elle pourrait séparer les enfants les uns des autres.
Elle pourrait les tenir à l'écart du monde extérieur.
Mais c'est à ce moment-là que Fred Rogers,
le présentateur de « Mister Roger's Neighborhood »,
a lancé le défi de voir la télévision comme un outil,
un outil pouvant promouvoir la croissance émotionnelle.
Voici ce qu'il a fait :
il nous regardait depuis l'écran et il tenait une conversation,
comme s'il parlait individuellement à chaque enfant,
sur les sentiments.
Puis il marquait une pause
et les laissait réfléchir à ces sentiments.
Vous voyez son influence dans tout le paysage médiatique actuel,
mais à l'époque, c'était révolutionnaire.
Il a changé notre regard sur la télévision dans la vie des enfants.
Aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas qu'une boite.
Les enfants sont entourés d'appareils.
Je suis aussi une mère, je comprends cette anxiété.
Mais j'aimerais que nous considérions trois peurs répandues
que les parents ont
et que nous voyions si nous pouvons déplacer notre attention
vers l'opportunité qu'il y a dans chacune d'entre elles.
Alors.
Peur numéro un :
« Les écrans sont passifs.
Ils vont empêcher nos enfants de se lever et de bouger. »
Chris Kratt et Martin Kratt sont des frères, tous deux zoologistes,
qui présentent une émission sur les animaux : « Wild Kratts ».
Ils ont approché l'équipe de PBS en disant :
« Pouvons-nous utiliser ces caméras
qui sont intégrées à tous les appareils ?
Pourraient-elles enregistrer le jeu très naturel d'un enfant :
prétendre qu'il est un animal ? »
Nous avons commencé par les chauves-souris.
Quand les enfants sont venus jouer à ce jeu,
ils ont adoré se voir à l'écran avec des ailes.
Mais ce que j'ai préféré :
que se passait-il une fois le jeu terminé et les écrans éteints ?
Ils continuaient à faire les chauves-souris.
Ils continuaient à voler dans la pièce,
à virer à gauche et à droite pour attraper des moustiques.
Ils se souvenaient de certaines choses.
Ils se souvenaient que les chauve-souris volent la nuit,
que quand les chauves-souris dorment,
elles se suspendent la tête en bas et plient leurs ailes.
Ce jeu a fait lever et bouger les enfants.
En plus, quand les enfants vont dehors,
ils regardent les oiseaux et se disent :
« En quoi un oiseau vole-t-il différemment de moi
lorsque j'étais une chauve-souris ? »
La technologie numérique a suscité un apprentissage concret
que les enfants peuvent utiliser dans le monde.
Peur numéro deux :
« Jouer à des jeux sur ces écrans est une perte de temps.
Cela va distraire les enfants de leur éducation. »
Les développeurs de jeux savent
que les compétences d'un joueur sont révélées
par les données :
où un joueur a-t-il appuyé sur pause ?
Où a-t-il fait quelques erreurs avant de trouver la bonne réponse ?
Mon équipe voulait appliquer cet outil à l'apprentissage académique.
Notre producteur à Boston, WBGH,
a créé une série de jeux, « George le curieux »,
axée sur les maths.
Des chercheurs ont fait jouer 80 enfants à ces jeux.
Puis ils ont fait passer à chacun des 80 enfants
un test standardisé en maths.
Nous avons vite pu voir
que ces jeux aidaient les enfants
à comprendre certaines compétences clés.
Mais nos partenaires à UCLA voulaient que nous creusions plus profond.
Ils travaillent sur l'analyse de données et l'évaluation des élèves.
Ils voulaient prendre les données du jeu
et voir s'ils pouvaient les utiliser pour prédire la note d'un enfant en maths.
Ils ont mis en place un réseau neuronal -- ils ont entraîné l'ordinateur
à utiliser ces données
et voici les résultats.
C'est un échantillon des notes des enfants au test standardisé de maths.
Et ça,
c'est la prévision de l'ordinateur pour chacune des notes des enfants,
basée sur les jeux « George le curieux ».
La prévision est incroyablement exacte,
surtout si l'on considère le fait que ces jeux n'ont pas été conçus
pour l'évaluation.
L'équipe ayant mené cette étude croit que de tels jeux
peuvent nous en apprendre plus sur l'apprentissage cognitif d'un enfant
qu'un test standardisé.
Et si les jeux pouvaient réduire la durée des examens en classe ?
Et s'ils pouvaient réduire l'anxiété liée aux examens ?
Comment pourraient-ils offrir aux professeurs des informations
pour les aider à mieux se concentrer sur l'apprentissage individualisé ?
La troisième peur dont je veux parler
est celle qui, à mon avis, est souvent la plus grande.
La voici :
« Ces écrans m'isolent de mon enfant. »
Jouons ce scénario.
Disons que vous êtes un parent
et qu'il vous faut 25 minutes sans interruption
pour préparer le dîner.
Afin de faire cela, vous donnez une tablette à votre enfant de trois ans.
C'est un moment où vous vous sentez probablement très coupable
de ce que vous venez de faire.
Imaginez ceci :
20 minutes plus tard, vous recevez un SMS
sur ce téléphone portable qui est toujours à portée de main.
Le SMS dit : « Alex a apparié cinq mots qui riment.
Demandez-lui de jouer à cela avec vous.
Peux-tu trouver un mot qui rime avec « chat » ?
Ou avec « ballon » ?
Dans nos études, quand les parents reçoivent de tels conseils simples,
cela les dynamise.
Ils sont si enthousiastes
de jouer à ces jeux lors du dîner avec leurs enfants.
Et les enfants les adorent aussi.
Non seulement ils pensent que c'est magique que leurs parents
sachent à quoi ils jouaient,
en plus les enfants adorent jouer avec leurs parents.
Le simple fait de parler des médias à des enfants
peut être incroyablement efficace.
L'été dernier, l'université Texas Tech a publié une étude
disant que l'émission « Daniel Tiger's Neighborhood » pourrait favoriser
le développement de l'empathie chez les enfants.
Mais il y avait une chose importante dans cette étude :
les effets bénéfiques les plus importants
n'arrivaient que si les parents parlaient aux enfants
de ce qu'ils avaient regardé.
Juste regarder
ou juste en discuter ne suffisait pas,
la clé était la combinaison des deux.
Quand j'ai lu cette étude,
j'ai commencé à penser
à quel point il est rare que des parents parlent aux enfants du contenu
de ce à quoi ils ont joué ou qu'ils ont regardé.
Alors j'ai décidé d'essayer avec mon fils de quatre ans.
J'ai dit :
« Jouais-tu à un jeu de voiture tout à l'heure ? »
Benjamin s'est redressé et a dit :
« Oui ! Tu as vu que ma voiture était faite d'un cornichon ?
C'était très dur d'ouvrir le coffre. »
(Rires)
Cette conversation hilarante sur ce qui était amusant dans le jeu
et ce qui aurait pu être mieux
a continué sur le chemin de l'école.
Je ne suis pas là pour vous suggérer
que tout ce qui est numérique est très bon pour les enfants.
Il y a des raisons légitimes de nous inquiéter
quant à l'état actuel du contenu pour enfants
sur ces écrans.
Il est bon de réfléchir à un équilibre :
où les écrans ont-ils leur place plutôt que toutes les autres choses
qu'un enfant doit faire pour apprendre et grandir ?
Mais quand nous concentrons nos peurs là-dessus,
nous oublions un élément majeur :
les enfants vivent dans le même monde que nous,
le monde où les adultes vérifient leur téléphone
plus de 50 fois par jour.
Les écrans font partie de la vie des enfants.
Et si nous prétendons le contraire
ou si notre peur nous accable,
les enfants n'apprendront jamais comment et pourquoi les utiliser.
Et si nous élevions nos attentes
au sujet de ce média ?
Et si nous parlions régulièrement aux enfants
du contenu qui est sur ces écrans ?
Et si nous cherchions l'influence positive
que cette technologie peut avoir dans la vie de nos enfants ?
C'est là que le potentiel de ces outils peut devenir une réalité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)